I think you took more notes than I did
what do you have anything pertinent to
the case you think yeah I have a couple
circles and a couple squiggly lines
which kind of just capture the emotional
trauma the oh so you just were doodling
the whole time yeah plus there's lines
here too okay
have you heard a better demo tape I'm
not talking about the quality of the
music yeah about the quality of the
recording she clearly paid big bucks
oh no I have a pipe being banged in the
background ordering this well I mean
that's straight out of the cocoa Rosie
playbook okay it sounds really like
they're in a kitchen with pots and pans
probably a high-traffic area I don't
even know if there was music associated
I think there was I can't remember it
was shot a more like whining or some
just a what you know the sound the wind
makes when it's yeah
trapped yeah maybe she was at a bottle
in the Chinna confidence and she was
like she was didn't seem like I seemed
like I could be very insulting and she
just smiled and laughing off and yeah
yeah like this she's doing this a lot
you know yeah it's kind of like oh
really oh I didn't I touch the back of
my head I don't even I'm doing it right
now every time I'm still doing here -
although he's still talking about he had
some tells to it I can't even do it like
that bad I'm just like I don't know what
that adds to I know the whoopie pie was
well I don't know such I was very hard
just like look someone hit her with a
shrink ray before he went out this was a
me it was like this big but it was being
really rushed and they couldn't great
but it like went a little bit too small
there was no time we had to like spill
on the scene Mike teavee from really
walkin II just i back
[Music]